-Kate, you look gorgeous
and stunning as always.
-Thanks, Jimmy!
-Welcome back to the show.
Last time I saw you,
we played "That's My Jam."
-Oh, my God.
-And you were --
-I was nuts.
-No, you were fantastic.
-Was I okay?
-You and your brother.
What do you mean? Okay?
All-star performance.
-I feel like --
Honestly, I left there,
and I called my brother.
I was like, "Did I come
across, like, crazy?
Was I way too competitive?"
-No, you were great 'cause
you knew all the answers.
I mean, you know music
and you can sing.
And you're fun.
-I had so much fun.
-You crushed it.
-And I had never been
on a game before,
and I was like, "Oh,
this could be a career for me."
I just want to go
and do all these games.
-It was so fun.
I was just talking about you,
'cause our buddy, the great
Cameron Crowe, was on the show.
-He was. I saw it.
-Did you see it?
-I saw the tiny dancer when he,
like, invited you on the show.
Are you going to do that?
-Yeah. I might do it.
"Almost Famous"
is on Broadway.
-Yes.
-So, that's the big news.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I say "we" were in it.
I say "we" were in it.
I was barely in it.
You were in it.
-Yeah, but you were in it.
-I kind of was in it,
but you're the star.
And I had a little part in it.
And Cameron said, "If you
want to, you can go up on stage
and be the manager of the..."
-Oh.
-And I would be like --
I know. It was amazing.
So I met the cast.
-Were they so sweet?
-The most talented --
-I actually met the girl
playing Penny Lane
in Toronto,
when "Glass Onion"
was premiering.
She had a movie that was
premiering, she came up to me.
-No way.
And I was like --
-She's great.
-Oh, she was so sweet.
-Does it bring you back?
Do you remember doing it?
Do you remember filming or no?
-I mean, of course.
-Right.
-What do you mean?
It was so --
I mean, that is -- For me,
"Almost Famous" is just like --
I mean, it's just in my brain.
I mean, I think it'll be
the most memorable experience
I had.
-But Cameron told me
that people dress
like your character,
like Penny Lane,
coming to the show
in the audience.
-That might feel like
a nightmare for me.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
I know. I know.
-Well, also just, like,
all these Penny Lanes,
like, what does it mean?
-Yeah.
-You know?
-We got to go.
We have to go together.
-We have to go.
Listen. I want --
If I'm going to go --
Which I definitely have to.
-Let's go together.
-I can't do it alone.
I need, like, you and Billy.
-Let's do it. Let's have
a little reunion and go.
-Oh, we had so much fun
on this movie, you guys.
-No, I mean, laughing and crying
laughing every single day.
But you crushed it. I love it.
And --
-I'm so happy for Cameron,
too, that, like, you know --
That must have been
really interesting for him
kind of reliving it and trying
to translate it for the stage.
-But, also,
it's his life, as well.
-Crazy.
-On top of it.
Did you sing on the soundtrack
of "Almost Famous" or no?
-No.
-You didn't sing.
-No, no.
-Because you can sing.
-I love to sing.
-Yeah.
-I'm -- Yeah. Yeah.
No. I just feel weird saying
it because I --
-"I'm" -- You can't --
That is a cliffhanger.
What if you just said,
"I'm -- We'll be right back."
"I'm --"
-"And see you guys later."
-You're making a record?
-I've been making a record
for like a year.
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-Kate!
-Yeah, yeah.
-Yes!
-It's so fun.
-Wait. That's fantastic.
-You know, I had this thing
at COVID -- everyone --
Every time you're doing
interviews, people are like,
"Do you have any regrets?"
I go, "I'm early 40s."
Like, not yet.
-"Not yet. I don't
have any regrets. Yeah.
-But during COVID, I was like,
you know, what am I doing?
I actually write -- I've been
writing music since I was 19.
And, like, I've never shared it.
And so I just thought that would
be one of my great regrets.
Like, I have no expectations.
-Yeah. Why not just do it?
-I just want
to put a record out.
-That's exactly right.
-And so I'm doing it.
And I'm really excited.
I can't wait.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-When? Next year?
-Next year. Yeah. Next year.
-If you feel comfortable, come
on our show and sing a song.
-I will. Oh, I will.
-We will play with you
and we'll have fun.
-I will definitely do that.
-Alright, buddy. I love you.
Alright, I want to talk about
"Glass Onion:
A Knives Out Mystery."
-Yeah. Oh, my gosh.
This movie is so fun.
-I know. I don't want to ruin
anything or spoil anything.
I never do. So I won't.
-Okay.
-But the whole cast
is great in this.
-Well -- Yeah.
-Go.
-No, you go.
-I am --
releasing an album next year.
[ Laughter ]
-I -- Honestly,
this was another --
I mean, you have
few great experiences.
Kurt always says, like,
every ten years, you know,
if you're lucky, you get
another great experience
making a movie, where, like,
everything kind of fits.
-Yeah. And this is one of them?
-That's what this felt like.
It really was like --
-Well, it crushed.
It came out --
They did some experiment thing.
It came out in the theaters.
Crushed. I mean, broke records.
And then went away.
-I know.
-Very mysterious.
-Very.
-Very Glass Onion-y.
-A true "Knives Out" mystery.
-Yeah. What is a mystery?
What is real life?
-But I really feel, like, what
was so wonderful about that
was that we -- people
want to go to see movies.
-You said people
were in the crowd
when you went to the premiere
and it was like "Rocky."
-Yeah. It was like --
-People were screaming,
going, "Yeah!"
-Yeah. I mean, it was wild.
-That's fun.
-It was so fun.
-To get that experience
on a big screen.
-In front of 1,500 people.
So, the first time I saw it --
I hadn't seen it before.
I saw it in front
of 1,500 people,
so I was already sweating
and had a bit of a migraine.
-Yeah, you're freaking out.
-Oh.
But the second
the crowd started,
it was like --
oh, man, this is a blast.
-It's a party. I want to read
one review that stuck out.
Plug your ears
if I'm going to embarrass you.
-Yeah. This is --
I don't like these things.
-Daily Beast says, in part,
"Kate Hudson absolutely kills
in 'Glass Onion:
A Knives Out Mystery.'
Hudson steals the show.
-Oh! Ohh!
-It might just be her
sharpest performance yet."
-Aah!
-Come on, Kate Hudson!
Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my God!
-Ooh-la-la.
-I love that.
That makes me feel good.
-That makes you feel good?
-I'm glad that you read that.
I don't like reading anything.
-No, that's my job.
-Because I feel weird.
-No, no.
-Then I'll go down
a rabbit hole.
-No. It's well done.
You've got that.
Can we set up your character
at all?
-Yeah, Birdie Jay --
which was actually --
It's my nickname.
So, my dad, Kurt, has called me
Birdie my whole life.
It was sort of --
Immediately when I read it,
I was like,
"Oh, Birdie. That's easy."
-That's weird.
-That feels good.
But Birdie Jay
is not a lot like me.
I mean, she says things
that she shouldn't.
-Yeah.
-She's very uncensored.
-Um, she's bold, flamboy--
-What does she do for a living?
-She -- I mean,
she has a sweatpants company.
-Mm-hmm.
[ Laughter ]
-And -- [ Laughs ]
-Okay.
-And she is like a --
kind of was a model-ish...
-Yep. Okay.
-...socialite vibes.
-Okay.
-Right?
Yeah. One of those.
-Yep.
-And she -- Miles Bron,
Edward Norton.
He plays the billionaire.
We're all going to his island,
and we're all kind of
connected to Miles
because he basically pays for
everything that we're all doing.
-Yep.
-And Birdie is, like,
the big, flamboyant one.
And that's -- I mean, that's
as much as I can say really.
-That's all you can say,
is that there's a murder.
Can we say that?
-Oh, yeah. There's a murder.
-And someone did it.
-And everyone
is a great character.
-Oh, my God. It's so fun.
And so funny.
-But you knock it
out of the park.
It's so good.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Kate Hudson in "Glass
Onion: A Knives Out Mystery."
Take a look at this.
♪♪
-Lionel, you are too sexy
to be a scientist.
And, Claire, you look so cute!
-Aww. Thanks, Bird.
-You really try.
I like that.
You really make an effort.
-Well, I figured. Greece.
-And no mask.
I can breathe again.
Look at this pool.
I think I'll go for a swim.
[ Music swells ]
Maybe I'll lay out for a bit.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on!
Who doesn't like that?
Kate Hudson. Unbelievable.
"Glass Onion:
A Knives Out Mystery"
premieres on Netflix
December 23rd.
Morris Chestnut joins us
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.